well thank you jen cohen thank you for
ourselves on back for your very kind
words and for the price it takes it's a
service annoying to get a prize because
you feel always humbled by the situation
I'm sure you understand that and the two
measures I think I have the prize are
one the distinction of the place of
learning where you getting the prize and
I think candy melon is as high as i can
think of and then the list of previous
people who've got in the prize and
that's an extraordinary list i looked at
it didn't know everybody but those i
knew what extraordinary scientists so
it's quite humbling honestly to me to do
that there are a number of announcements
in the press over the last what two
years now talking about ocean
acidification and I think the nicest
idea was a study of the evil twin I like
that idea of global warming the National
Academy in New York Times Washington
Post all have talked about it as being
an important problem and it's a lot of
lack of knowledge on the subject and I
try to share that lack of knowledge with
you which is the best I can do today so
let's start we're at the start okay
carbon dioxide as varied for the last
well actually this record from ice cores
who back now million years and it goes
up if I can find it during interglacials
down the relational times back and now
we're here somewhere in the interglacial
at the beginning of the industrial era
and then I'm going to make it work here
we go we have actual data for moon Aloha
you are familiar with those data from
Dave Keeling since the late 50s and it's
beautiful record on top of the mountain
3,000 meters showing the yearly cycle of
co2 and its increase over the last
number of years when it's gone from 330
at the beginning which is already a
higher actually than the values that
have been found in the ring interglacial
332 390 today
the record actually extends further than
what i have here and then we have to
extrapolate to the futures have to
change scales and here's a prediction
for the where 20 of 20 100 so there is a
range of prediction but all of them you
see dwarf would happen for the last
million years or so so we have a very
large increase in co2 now do we know
what happens to that co2 well in part we
do and live in stations now in the world
hot swell bats and s talk well that's
Bermuda Atlantic time series which is at
Bermuda never nebula hot switch is in
hawaii hawaii ocean time series you know
people like those funny names of course
acronyms and the Europeans I've come up
with a stock which is a short dagger and
they stuck in the show dagger in its
European station time ocean series up
right from the acronyms all of that and
you see the days when they started
measuring carefully carbon dioxide and
other parameters in seawater okay here's
the data for manure or otherwise the
same as the hots i should say two
different names tim place bats and s doc
all of those show an increase in co2 you
can measure see you two in surface
seawater you see the yearly cycle goes
up in the winter down in the summer for
the synthesis is important and you have
a clear signal that you can measure the
increase on the order of point 1 point 5
28 Marco atmosphere ppm whatever per
year that's what's happening in terms of
co2 greater this you to go well mostly
on the surface and almost half of it is
at the very surface the oceans have
taken up about a third of this you to
that we are put into the atmosphere
since the beginning or the history old
times all right now we're getting to I
want to go co2 goes up so what all right
and so people have taken aquatic
chemistry from David all about it and
I'll see you my
version of aquatic chemistry which I
think you will enjoy because it's
literally simple here are the reactions
so i'm sorry i cannot give that talk
without any chemistry for those who
don't like chemistry i cannot help it i
need a minimum it is the minimum there
are three reactions okay it's not too
bad see you too gasps equally raged
between the gas and the aqueous phase
see you too reacts with water to give
you a proton and bicarbonate the
bicarbonate dissociates further to give
another hydrogen iron and the company
time also the three reactions what
happens see you too goes up what do it
co2 goes up if co2 goes up here does to
push the reaction to the right and it
does each plus goes up if h plus goes up
in the soup is the bottom reaction to
what happened to me input to lgb should
I worry about that no okay fine let's
not go this way all right so that's all
the chemistry for today we need that
that's all we needed co3 co2 increases
your three decreases and H+ increases
with the pH decreases I mean your pH
scale is one that was problem ph goes
down on I should tell you that the main
reaction really going on is co2 coming
from the atmosphere being essentially
reacting with the base carbonate to give
my company that's the main reaction in
seawater okay so we have three
parameters changing and that's what I'm
going to talk about and they are pretty
much independent of each other co2
carbon 8 h plus alright so i'll start
with co2 might be not quite okay first
is it true but I told you well the pH
decreases we can measure it the
carbonate decreases we can measure it
right so it's true in seawater we can
see the effects I just talked about now
I want you to remember a little bit the
pH by the way has gone up down down a
bit if you extrapolate roughly point one
pH unit since the bigot that's all
50 years Oh point one pH unit probably
going to go two point three breaths
point for pH units between now and 2100
okay that's a fair amount you know 3.3
piedras is a factor of two in each class
concentration so it's not a trivial
point all right co 3 goes down you might
want to remove this number for later on
the order 200 for example is the good
concentration look at later on all right
so have those three things changing
interacting with each other I'm going to
talk about three kinds of effects well
the first one is going to be
photosynthesis co2 in the photosynthesis
the circle one is carbonate ion and the
calcification and then pH which involved
all slew of effects and that's
complicated and I'll give some examples
how do we approach this problem or some
people actually want to monitor the
ocean more stations like that sand hot
sand so forth and more stations are
being installed right there some people
are looking at large enclosures and
sitting up big bags and making changes
and seeing what happens in those and
some people are doing lab cultures and
that's what I do and I'm probably
interested in molecular mechanisms and
the reason for that is it belief which
we can argue about at the end if you
want that we cannot generalize we cannot
extrapolate without some understanding
of cause and effect if you just do
experiments and merge with something not
sure what caused it is very difficult to
extrapolate from those experiments to
the whole ocean or to the future so but
the field has gone another way so what I
do is a bit different and the field has
gone mostly to this sort of experiments
and they exist in no away couple of
places beautiful experiments are in
South Korea you see of Washington and
the basic idea there is to fit fairly
large enclosures large enough that most
of what's in the surface water is going
to be in it okay and then you bubble co2
or do you do whatever and you carry the
experiments for several days we
weeks and then you look at the
difference between the treatments and
the control okay it's a very interesting
experiments the difficulty in my view is
that can use predict that the same thing
will happen in another package under the
same condition no because different
organisms will be there so it's very
difficult to go from one of those
experiments to a generalization to the
rest of the world by the way I can't see
you you know you can see me but I'm
blinded by the other light I feel like
in Hollywood or something have no idea
was over there except when I do this
yeah I say it's a test okay all right so
what we do the lab experiments and I'll
show you something and we try to
understand things that I so mechanistic
level and that's a postdoc in my lab
actually doing experiments all right and
so your approach this of course we can't
deal with all these interacting
processors we take them one at a time
and simplify the problem and try to go
on see you two in photosynthesis here's
my idea what for the synthesis is about
two reactions one is a light reaction
capturing light energy splitting water
making oxygen and give us reductant to
do the dark reaction the dark reaction
is separate from the light reaction and
there it involves co2 being fixed into
organic matter all right now what's
interesting about a second reaction dark
reaction that it depends on a number of
enzyme where the key enzyme the one that
does the carboxylation is rubisco okay
you genzyme 540 kilo dalton lots of
subunits as you can see very ancient
enzyme and almost all the plants in the
world use that enzyme its most abundant
enzyme in the world according to most
people not sure that's true but sounds
good sounds good and why is it so
abundant because it's allows the enzyme
it is really bad enzyme it's extremely
slow turns over just a few times a
second there's a very bad affinity for
carbon dioxide and it has affinity for
ox ox Egan it's a carboxylase oxygenase
at the end right so it polly was pretty
good a couple of billion years ago when
there was a lot of carbon dioxide
no oxygen but now that we have low
carbon dioxide and lots of oxygen it's a
pretty lousy enzyme the net result is
that they sent co2 actually is under
saturated in most plants and you may or
may not know this but people have been
studying the effect of co2 on land
plants as is it increasing in the world
a big experiment unbind Duke University
and I things in the Duke forest and
they've been doing open face what is it
call face anyway it doesn't matter and
the point that we've been increasing co2
and the result is that you see in net
increase in the growth of plants and
I've seen a report just before coming
here from my colleagues at Princeton and
the estimate is that were it not for
this effect of co2 on plant growth the
increase of co2 in the atmosphere would
be eighty percent larger than it is now
so it's an enormous effect on socio to
fertilization is not a trivial effect
it's accounted for by the in all the
predictions so it's a very large effect
on land plants and the question is
should it also occur in marine plants in
phytoplankton and we expect or expected
that it should and I'll tell you why so
this is my most difficult slide this is
a phytoplankton this is the outside
membrane this is a chloroplast and this
is a concentration of carbon dioxide
outside this is the enzyme rubisco and
the problem is that 10 micro molar is
not enough to make the enzyme work well
it's completely under saturated so what
do the plant whether the phytoplankton
do they do this not beautiful okay they
increased co2 they pop it up inside the
cell to a value which is about 60
macromol also and by the way that's a
tricky because in fact the membranes are
very variable to see or two so you pump
it in but it keeps leaking out now it's
like a leaky bucket bring water in it so
its extent of work to do that and the
enzymes that are involved in number of
them but one of them which is a key is
carbonic anhydrase check will see a in
this case and so we expected fully that
if increase co2
less energy would be spent pumping the
carbon this CCM calvin clinical be less
energy spat on that and we see an
increase in North right right so what do
we see well if we look at the enzyme
that really works are we start at low
co2 we increase you to the amount of
enzyme really decreases the amount of
enzyme necessary for pumping the carbon
goes down we can measure that very well
we do experiments no change in growth
rates you're going to feel no changing
growth rate well in some cases we see
changes sometimes considered that but
the reality that we do not see infielder
lab experiment is systemic large
fertilization by co2 as we see in land
plants do we know why no okay so we have
some ideas and maybe seen interaction
imaginary second but the lesson from
that is that what may have been a
positive effect of co2 right it's very
negative feedback and increase in the
growth of plants in the sea as they are
on land is not occurring as far as we
can tell which is sort of interesting
why in fact we don't see a result
perhaps interaction among their
parameters and we're trying to
understand that the pH change is
negating the effect of co2 anyway we
don't know the answer at this time okay
calcification all right so a bit more
chemistry but not really bad okay
calcium carbonate precipitation calcium
carbonate it occurs if this carbonate is
greater than this value for saturation
calcium in seawater is constant okay
it's too much of it it doesn't change so
carbonate high enough you go this way
carbonate too low you go the other way
right that's simple two kinds of calcium
carbonate calcite and aragonite
different forms of calcium carbonate
precipitated by different kinds of
organisms ah alright so this is with how
to read perhaps three lines on each of
those graphs the
red dotted line is the value at which
carbonate is just saturated for either
aragonite or calcite all right the blue
is the range of saturation of calcite as
a function of time from 1900 to 2100 and
the green one is a calcite aragonite and
calcite calcite being more stable is
more super saturated in what you see
that in general most regions of the
world we're going to keep a super
saturation of calcite and aragonite
however if you look at high latitudes
you're going to find that we predict is
under saturation of aragonite in
particular sometime around mid century
right why is it so different in high
latitudes there are two factors one it's
colder and those those particular
precipitate cancel a dragonite do not
form as easily in cold water when you
put your pen on the on the on the stove
you see the calcite precipitating
because heat makes it precipitate so
lower temperature makes it less
saturated and the second reason has to
do with the carbonyl chemistry of
seawater where in fact it's less
buffered at high latitudes so you end up
with a system which is not as saturated
so there are possibilities here of an
under saturated just improbability
system what organism is precipitated
calcium carbonate many organism many
many marine organisms love to meet
calcium carbonate I'll talk about a few
examples cause of course you know all
about those and they precipitate
recognized Carini algae which are the
red interesting thing also important in
coral reefs but everywhere in the world
make calcite molly's like mussels and
oysters make make a rag a night and
calcite they are mixed in the the inside
of this beautiful piece of rag a night
in the outside is calcite telepods which
are those little snails and that
actually swim in the surface of the
ocean they all make a ragga night and
coke lethal force which are
phytoplankton make this beauty
calcium carbonate calcite left on the
outside this is very intricate thing all
right so many other organisms make that
by the way I should say that crabs and
lobsters and sea urchins and starfish
all make calcium carbonate and need to
be custom carbonate to survive so
calcium credit is important and it's
been the major worry of people
interested in a certification calcium
carbonate precipitation and the effect
on the organisms that need to do it so
here is some data on corals showing a
change in the extent of calcification in
minimal meter square per day as a
function of this is the carbonate ion
concentration you can also together see
you too if you want and you see we were
200 before whatever you have to go
pretty far to get a point where you'll
not have net calcification but you see
decrease in classification with
decreasing co 3 increasing acidity now
those experiments which are the best
published on the subject we are done you
will never believe this in biosphere to
remember with bus fare to was in the
desert of Arizona and paid for by mr.
bass with it takes us millionaire
billionaire oil and they had this big
enclosure in the fake ocean and they
grow corals and it could do nice
experiment select that's what this data
come from actually which is interesting
it's hard to get lots of it was a good
data on coal and calcification they go
all over the place now come back to that
arm muscles so I took of course the
French love to eat mussels and oysters
they have worked on this and you can
finally change in classification but
look at the numbers which we're getting
now 195 230 remember we here somewhere
right it doesn't really matter we're
still going to have oysters and clams
have you haven't we still are going to
have must any oysters where we find
that's not the biggest worry now I've
been working myself on the coca leaf 04
also natural somebody else's data I
should tell you we find numbers that are
very valuable species to species
condition to condition and I chose those
data because they
they exemplify the arrow bars okay no
miss changes just adjust the size of the
lift the coca leaf each of those little
plates on top I've been measured and you
can see as a function of carbonate the
change in the sides but look at the
error bars it's completely meaningless I
mean we really don't have a systematic
results are published I'm a co-author of
an article which is widely published
saying that in fact it does a large
effect well we haven't been able to do
it too well okay so it's been difficult
to show a large effect on aretha
falls very difficult and so Scott done
yet with all polish the paper i think
that's p99 but he would do that same now
and here is the kind of thing that he
does up scares me you have here your
first reports everybody sees a decrease
in calcification any experiments it goes
up and then it goes up because back then
essentially not very systematic set of
data on the effect of acidification on
the calcification of marine organism and
why is that why is that so i think
there's a very recent paper in 2013 19
months ago roughly in the preceding of
national academy of science by a group
for Monica now you made a disk medicos
may be the smallest country in the world
or close to it is very small it switched
before it's more but there's a very
distinguished tradition of Oceanography
because the princes in the mine love
oceanography and they went on the
sailboat it in oceanography polish big
reports and there is a big center of
oceanography and one thing they're
really good at is coral second really
study corals very good people doing that
in Morocco so if you want to work in
Monaco you with you work on Cole's okay
and then so this study is interesting
because it sort of explains the
difficulty the this is a coral this is
the name of that Colonel I don't work
with coral and working here at the space
which is between the skeleton okay sea
water and just a barrier between the sea
water and what's at the surface of the
skeleton there is it
a compartment if you want in which the
chemistry is partly controlled by the
organism and for example if some data
here's the ph of seawater and is a ph
actually measured in that compartment
which is a very difficult thing to do
and what you can see that it does change
with the ph of seawater but not exactly
one to one it's actually buffered right
and you could lower the pH well the the
Delta the difference gets larger and
interestingly enough they are self data
they're showing that for deep-sea corals
which are stable even in very
understated seawater the inside the pH
that doesn't change at all and so
there's an ability by those organism to
control the pH in the compartment in
which the calcite that the aragonite is
formed and so depending on the exact
organism you get more or less of a
response depending on whether you allow
them to control that pH you get a
response so this great complication it's
not something which happens because
simply of the chemistry outside depends
a great deal where the organism can do
in controlling the chemistry at the
point of interest all right p edge
effects all right so I'm going back for
examples and two of them discuss a bit
more pho metastasis all right so all
organisms control the internal pH in
unison an organism notice know you do
the ph of your budget 7.4 is very much
controlled it's requires energy to do so
is there a cost of an advantage of
changing the pH of seawater from that
point of view what we don't quite know
but some of my colleagues think that if
you look at organisms I don't have a
very high very high level of pumping of
oxygen and co2 in low metabolism and
that in vertebrates perhaps those might
be very sensitive and they may not be
able to cope with a change in pH I don't
know we don't see much effect in the
organisms with which I work we work on
something else this is the external
enzymes for example maxwell's you have
enzymes on the outside and those things
I'm of course a ph-sensitive lacroix
enzyme are and in this case we look at
an enzyme which takes organic phosphorus
are here breaks it apart to get the
phosphate negating phosphate and picks
it up they need the phosphate and this
enzyme is quite ph-sensitive it's called
alkaline phosphatase it lacks iph it
doesn't like low pH so it may be
affected by the decrease in pH we've
worked on the question of the change in
chemistry due to ph of the metals that
are essential for the growth of
organisms in this case we're talking
about iron which goes from iron as in an
organic iron in water and being complex
to complexing agent swear most of the
iron in sea water is actually key lated
to the very interesting complexing
agents and that changes you have
availability of iron and then there many
other possibilities and the well I'll
talk about is when we worked on recently
which is the question of Legends
fixation in the ocean very briefly all
right back to metal diagram and reason
I'm putting that here is because iron
one of the major role of iron in factory
plankton is to allow for the synthesis
for the system two and one which operate
the machinery capture the light and make
it into a chemical energy per unit of
that there are 22 iron atoms say a lot
of iron is devoted to actually capturing
sunlight okay so that's important for
photosynthesis so here's an example of
where the chemistry talking about we're
taking iron which is in the water earth
and just add vaccinated in this case
react with protons and you might go from
what's available what's unavailable to
actually bound to a chelating agent does
that actually occur yes it does occur in
the lab experiments we can see that if
you go from ph 8.6 27.7 the uptick rate
of iron by this organism goes down
dramatically but if you calculate the
change in the chemistry and you plot
with the this form of iron the free iron
it's all this in line so the effect is
strict
the chemical it has nothing to do with
biology it's just a change in the
chemistry between they are in less
available because of the binding to
chelating agent does that occur in the
seawater well we see a decrease in
seawater is it going to really open all
the time what will depend what happens
to the cycle of iron in the world so
it's complicated yes the effect exists
will it be important we don't know n 2
fixation some organism can actually take
n 2 from the atmosphere and make it into
ammonium and make it available to
themselves and other organisms ah it's a
very important reaction in sea water
because but I should have mentioned that
before nitrogen is limiting but half of
the world's ocean are unlimited maybe
forty percent are unlimited and maybe
ten percent are phosphorus in silicon
limited okay so when I'm talking about
nitrogen and our and every reason
because I those are very much limiting
nutrients in the ocean alright so those
organisms that fixed nitrogen really
help ocean ecosystems and one organism
of interest is this fellow trick Odessa
miam it's actually a sign of bacterium
it gets into the Sloan bundles and gets
together into the sheath and you can see
you got season by you can see individual
member of this bye-bye I if you're
swimming Sargasso Sea for example it
gives on that long streaks of those in
the ocean it's quite dramatic and here
is a diagram of where those are found
and you can find them you see we work
sometimes near Bermuda over there so we
can find them here but they are pretty
prevalent in the world ocean and mostly
here in the Pacific and the Atlantic and
also the Indian Oceans both north and
south what's the enzyme doing the job is
nitrogen is another begins I'm 340k
philadel t'en is the reaction and it's a
very complex reaction not completely
understood it involves the other
reductase and hotel reductase and this
actual nitrogen is in the middle
ah so we've done experiments with this
and what we find is a clear decrease in
the effectiveness of the natural
journeys to fix nitrogen under acid
conditions we don't quite know why but
we see an increase in production of
hydrogen and we think it may have to do
with the some inefficiency in the enzyme
don't quite understand there is a
tendency to reduce h plus 2 h 2 rather
than reducing n22 nh3 when we decrease
the pH so why is that happening and not
quite sure but that's what they did
actually show does this always occur no
so we send some undergraduate students
in the near Bermuda and they do the
experiment what they like to do that
actually not I'm happy to do that it
turns out and what they did is you know
they collected one by one with pipette
those little things the Tufts of
organism put them in the bottle add all
the nutrients except natural gin and
then change the pH well co2 and version
what's happening in these them average
result right here it clear increase okay
so opposite is there a reason for that
well there are at least two possible
reasons one is that of course they have
all the other nutrients were in the lab
and the very controlled conditions were
limited the iron for example also they
collected those fairly large aggregates
of cells which means that co2 diffusion
becomes a real problem and higher co2
becomes really beneficial in that case
well in our single cell system it does
not have care so there is a another
reason and we think that the co2 effect
becomes important in the collection in
the collected drink ohms and it's not
important in the lab the single cell
alright complications I like a little
thing it's like a watch swiss watch
ocean warming
alright the problem with sitting ocean
acidification is that it's not happening
all by itself other things are changing
in the ocean and I want to mention the
warming and the mixing the temperature
increases so in the future we're going
to have a surface ocean plus 3 plus 6
degrees we don't know better first a few
degrees what does that do well first of
all it's changing temperature so the
organisms have a change in pH but also a
change in temperature how does that work
together then because it's warmer you
get a stratification because shallower
we change the stratification of the
surface ocean which means that you get
less input of nutrients from the bottom
the chain is a change in the input of
nitrogen or iron or phosphorus to the
surface water for the cells to grow and
then because if you are shallower you
end up with in fact more light in there
because you don't go as deep so the
phytoplankton of the surface have more
light so you changing the pH you're
changing weather co2 as I've told you in
the carbonate but you're also changing
the temperature the nutrient input and
the yridians well that's a lot of
changes to account for in the same
experiments right so we do one thing at
a time because we're scientists we don't
we don't let you see the difficulty
involved in predicting what will happen
the other problem of course this
question of time scales we're fortunate
when we study you know the primary
producers of the ocean because they grow
fast and we can actually study them in a
matter of days they can actually grow we
can do experiment the last a few days if
you study forest you can't do an
experiment in few days we can big
advantage but we still stuck with a
problem of succession and adaptation
acklam jetted mutation and that will
take time that we don't have time to
study in the lab there's no way and how
do we extrapolate how we understand that
it's friendly very difficult okay so
when we talk of change in ecosystems you
know how do we deal with this question
of evolution or change of invading
species that were actually better
adapted to the
environment so you know it's very
interesting work we can do lots of
interesting science and its than the
mechanism and everything okay very
complex problem and it's perhaps
worrisome some organisms are going to
pay price I think the most likely are
going to be the corals because they are
affected by the pH they affected by the
temperature by other pollutions and I
think all reefs are the most likely
poster child of the effect ocean
acidification it doesn't kill them by
itself it doesn't do the job but with
other things it's a series of stresses
that are really putting pressure on on
cause I think other systems we don't
quite know if you calcifying organisms
may be in trouble in various places
people have talked of some of the snails
in the northern ocean and the important
thing for fish etc we don't know but it
seems to me that there would be some
effects okay so what I'm going to say
now is a personal opinion and my friends
we work in the same field would not be
happy with me okay so you keep very
small crowd here this is very hush-hush
you understand so I don't want you to
repeat that to anybody but my sense that
it is not the most pressing problem of
global change it's an important when we
should study it but there are other
problems that are more pressing and I
think there are two reasons for that and
the first one has to do with the fact
that indeed the ocean are based on the
food chain which is based on microscopic
organism so they can actually grow very
fast they can adapt they can invade and
in the fluid medium things can move very
quickly that's different from land trees
do not grow do not double every day
trees do not move my place to another
very fast ok so there's another problem
every to do with land and I think that
that first thing is scientific I think
is more likely for ocean ecosystem to
adapt the change in the environment than
from land ecosystem personal opinion ok
don't tell anybody the second part has
to do with the actual impact on people
self and Sandy here that affects people
directly more directly even than a
change in some coral reef frankly that
affects people in their life directly
more dramatically perhaps things like
drought we know that global change mix
dry dry places dry or wet places whether
we know that is no it's not mystery we
know it's going to happen it's happening
in Africa people are suffering from
great routes so there's a direct effect
on people which is more dramatic in some
other effects of global change so it's
not that sure thing as a feature is not
important but I think it has probably
more subtle effects and less direct the
effect on people okay so i get don't
tell my friends you yeah until the
career on that but i think the science
has to be done we have to understand
more but i think that there are very
pressing problems that are not addressed
on land okay this is my research group
and the people put the slides together
not me because I can't do that I've had
as ven grants a good German fellow in
working on those places before remember
that and Jamie young kim is she's well
actually put together those things in in
Korea and she's very good at making
slides and i'll leave you with this
slide and take questions if you have
questions this is a slide from this
knowing the baltic sea okay all right
I'm questions and there are some
microphones on the side and if you have
a questions and please raise your hand
and we'll get a microphone to you
there's a question in the best one hand
over there yes yes stand up oh I really
can't see if I don't okay I'm blinded
thank you for the presentation and would
you mind to say a few words about the
other side of the balance in other words
we're how about the calcium ions the
Gaza mines ok the museum 10 this point
01 molar calcium 2 plus in the ocean
that's in excess by a factor of a 10,000
for anything else of interest so it
doesn't change to a first approximation
that doesn't change ok so the calcium
iron to first approximation is constant
in our system we don't care all right
there's plenty of calcium in seawater to
make all the calcium carbonate in the
world that's not a problem ok great
excess of calcium ok so that's for us
that's easy but the hard part is a
carbonated yes the way I see it there
are two possible impact one is your
logical other is a biological which one
is more detrimental to an environment or
and more undesirable geological so I'm
sorry so if you're telling me that the
increase in co2 will change weathering
that may well be true but my talk was
only about ocean acidification so I
there's not much geological change in
the ocean right now remember the co2 is
only at the surface for now deep sea
water is under saturated anywhere
because of the pressure effect on
calcium carbonate they're not likely to
be a very large sort of chemical
geochemical geological effect that's
going to be miniscule for years and
years to come so the question is really
that of the impact on the organisms and
the on the ecosystem that the song
them inhabit ok so I think nobody really
is worried about the changes in
chemistry per se or geological things
like that I think is really very very
far down the line up of worries yes
no could you repeat the question repeat
the question first of all oh okay mr.
president just asked whether we should
dump a bunch of iron in the ocean the
idea is the following the honors of to
you is forty percent limited by the iron
availability much of that iron comes
actually from the atmosphere little
small iris or that follow the top of the
ocean dissolve and become available to
phytoplankton and last parts of the
ocean that's still limited by our
particularly the Southern Ocean large
for the Southern Ocean which is
contiguous around Antarctica is
unlimited and so will other than large
experiments you can add iron and things
grow more get more phytoplankton and the
ideas been haha it's at iron fertilizer
phytoplankton increase the settling of
phytoplankton to the deep which actually
increases minus u2 in deep sea water it
takes a thousand years for it to come
back well we we secretin co2 and people
by the way of thought that one that may
be one of the reasons why the co2 is
lower during glacial times during
glacial times a lot more wind much more
violent storms the Sarah desert gets all
around the world much more deposit for
my roles and that's maybe one of the
reasons not the whole thing maybe one of
the reasons why co2 is actually lower
English all times why not well I think
there are two reasons I think will be
completely inefficient one of the
problem is putting on in seawater II
that army is very insoluble in sea water
and so you put a lot of line but most of
it just goes to the bottom and so you
have a transient effect okay which means
that you actually get some bloom will
you do it and you get some export but
what have you done what you have done by
and large is to then exhaust the natural
gender was there which nitrogen of
course if it not been used there would
have continued being advected in other
places can be used so you're going to
crease fertility in one place to another
place and so your gain is actually quite
small right because of that in fact
something else is going to be growing
less and then there's a question of a
host of possible cascading effects and I
I think it's going to be extremely
expensive extremely inefficient and with
unknown consequences bad way to do
things doesn't opinion again oh they do
they do well that's what they that's
what they do yeah so the way this works
of course is that some fun actually fall
to the bottom but much of it doesn't
fall that way so it's eaten by
zooplankton and what's politically or
that they call fecal pellets fall down
or something beggar it said and so forth
and falls out so eventually some of the
biomass falls down it's very inefficient
when it comes from very small
phytoplankton because those become
essentially eaten up and then the
bacteria decompose said the whole thing
turns over at the top if you have large
enough phytoplankton you end up with one
of two things fish what you eat fish do
with diatoms basically or things falling
at the bottom which is called the
biological pump which pumps co2 to the
bottom of the ocean yes he look dead
sanitary saturation you have a sense of
how much that depth 20 varies as a
function of time yeah Maurice at
Princeton ok so again calcium Scott some
cabinets saturation we're talking about
and in the ocean a chasm cabin is
interesting which we take water which is
saturated with calcium carbonate and it
precipitates the volume actually expands
that's not obvious what's not true of
most solids it happens with calcium
carbonate actually takes more volume and
the calcium iron and the carbonate is
separated from each other the result of
that of course is that if you put high
pressure this is done as eat precipitate
less right because you don't want to
expand them so what high pressure
calcium carbonate is in precipitate as
much as well ok and so in the ocean
depending on where you are so pH effects
to confer basically as you get deep in
the ocean calcium carbonate is now today
under saturated all right the result of
which is that calcium carbonate is like
snow on the mountain it's near the coast
it's an anywhere that says they range in
the ocean you can find the top which is
full of calcium carbonate but not a
depth ok and so the question is whether
that line that depth changes with time
it does change of course of a geological
epoch we know that is it going to change
today well it will change you a little
bit but not very much and not right away
and so one of the question will be as we
acidify the ocean will there be a change
in the calcium carbonate cycle changing
a figma school they are telling ET of
the ocean is essentially compensating
for the effective acidification
essentially maintaining pH and so forth
constant the problem that the timeframe
for that is much much longer than a
century we're talking of thousands of
years so again we not predicting I'm not
trying to create thousands of years and
like to hope I could find five years and
be happy 10 be great 50 young we're
trying to do 100 years but thousands of
years is not even happen to us right now
oh okay so thinking of other effects I
think
that you know we're talking of storms
we're talking of drought I think sea
level changes can become dramatic they
may not have curve right away from those
people who may fairly slow but some
people in islands that are the level of
the ocean will be in trouble even New
York City could be in trouble right on
miami miami is very low so there ya sea
level rise so those are concerns it to
me look more dramatic than the
biological effect of ocean acidification
this question in the back yeah mention
you mentioned that in that in today's
time where we have like low levels of
co2 relative to you in high levels of
oxygen a rock co is a pretty lousy
enzyme and you suggest that that if the
good old days when co2 was much higher
yeah and maybe that's what were involved
but in these days the oceans must have
been much more acidic so how did any of
these organisms ever make any shells if
we're so close to not precipitate
precipitating anymore so he asking a
question of what does the chemistry of
the ocean more than three billion years
ago what you're asking okay and my first
answer is I have no idea okay but then
people of course have more ideas and me
and it will tell you answers you don't
have to believe that but if you will get
answers to the question what was the
SBA's chemistry of the ocean so the
problem is that you had a lot of time
true right and you had a lot of videos
sulfur right so you have to understand
that I've been oxidized on the self
video software to sulfate we acidified
the ocean liquid deal so we change the
alkalinity at the same time right seem
it's true for iron so one of the
complication after your question is what
other as base reactions have occurred in
the same time and it seems to me that
there are these two very important
reactions have to do with the redox
chemistry of iron and sulfur that
actually party compensate for your
question so I'm not sure that the ocean
was actually extremely acidic at the
time
okay but may have been you have partial
pressure of civil you know atmosphere or
whatever so it's a say good question I
we don't have a good understanding of
what happened them okay yes one more
question okay student with microphone
the back holy thank you we have two more
questions David okay all right thanks
professor so my question is based on
your talk advertising that the ocean
acidification who caused the decrease of
coral reefs so I personally assume that
it provides less protection for those
coastal cities and it probably an reason
for the disaster like sandy storms so so
my question is do you use do you see
that on a state of ocean acidification
has a prediction of some disasters or no
more errors or use it as an indication
of these kind of things okay first of
all I don't think that sandy was
affected in any way by by my coastal
reefs okay sandy came on there's no I
promise you can go diving around New
York there there's no coral reef there I
wish the recovery but it's a Hudson
River us nice place to die but okay it's
a it's not yes some places are protected
in part by coral reefs that's true and
if the way to disappear completely could
affect their sensitivity to rise in sea
level and other things and bad weather
it's true again it seems to me to be a
circle order to the civet II of the
storm themselves okay again sandy Polly
would go over any kind of score reef and
destroy lots of people like you see my
point i'm not i'm not saying that those
things don't exist try to argue for a
relative importance to human beings
that's all I'm saying okay yes this
affects cannot care okay but I think the
secondary to other effects yeah I said
sandy would have gone even if you're a
beautiful coral reef all over New Jersey
and Long Island and everything alright
in know right it you're the question
question as with as with mangrove swamps
coral reefs are the base of a lot of
ecosystems yes and so if in fact we see
a significant decline in coral reefs any
thought on the consequences for the
oceanic ecosystems that are you're
getting way out of my specialty i think
in deal they are very interesting
ecosystem on coral reefs and mangroves
and so forth and I'm not a specialist I
I thought they were all going to
disappear by the way it's very unlikely
but that there will be a decrease in
those yes and where is a good question
places like the MU de which applies call
rates are pretty far north for coral
reef those may survive very nicely those
are in warmer climate and getting warmer
make it worse i mean the temperature
effects by much important than a
acidification so you know the Great
Barrier Reef I don't know I frankly I
don't know the answer yes it's a very
interesting ecosystem and people are
padlet I should tell you of the people
working in that field those who have
most emotion about the subject of the
coal people they have great amount of
attachment to the systems and they are
as a result much more a panicky but at
least emotionally attached to you to the
ocean acidification as a problem and for
good reasons okay but I think from a
societal point of view it's again less
than that I think that's see my point
right and that boo yes a lot cooperates
I like diving so there's good reason to
go there thank you for
thank you